si dans ses jeunes années le prince
harry avait déjà beaucoup fait parler de
lui pour ses dérapages comme lorsqu'il
s'était déguisé en nazi lors d'une
soirée pour amuser ses amis voilà que
depuis quelques temps les britanniques
ont l'impression de l'avoir totalement
perdu prince rebelle par excellence le
jeune frère de william a décidé de
prendre du recul avec la couronne
l'angleterre après s'être éloigné de
buckingham de la reine et de ses
fonctions pour aller vivre avec meghan
markle à los angeles
les choses semblent se compliquer encore
plus avec la famille royale sans compter
les nombreuses interviews polémique il a
donné sur sa famille pourquoi êtes vous
parti le manque de soutien lors des
obsèques du prince philip à rio aurait
reçu un accueil glacial de la part du
clan windsor mountbatten récemment il ne
s'est même pas déplacé pour les 80 40 sa
grand mère la reine elizabeth
une attitude qui pourrait le conduire à
ne pas participer à l'hommage rendu le
1er juillet prochain la mémoire de la
princesse lady di en angleterre pourtant
pour la journaliste angela levin tout
est de la faute d' harry si vous essayez
de mettre votre famille en pièces vous
ne pouvez pas vous attendre à ce qu elle
se comporte comme si de rien n'était
pour éviter d'avoir une fois encore à se
rendre auprès de sa famille avec qui le
courant ne passe plus du tout harry
pourrait utiliser le prétexte de la
naissance de son prochain enfant en
quelques années harry semble avoir
détruit tout ce qui l'entourait au
profit de mégane et ses enfants des
choix qui pourraient lui coûter cher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non mais ça fait trois ans que je vois
mais regardez vous la préparez
est ce que le couple arrive egan est en
panne je sais pas mais en tout cas moi
je suis un détail un peu quelqu'un
dérange un peu c'est avec cette
interview chez oprah winfrey quand on a
vu les deux qui étaient assis l'un à
côté de l'autre
à chaque fois qu'ils voulaient prendre
la parole médiane qui mettait la main
sur sa main et sur son genou en mode
t'inquiète pas je sais que j'ai la
culotte c'est moi qui pilotent congo
savez les i je gère poids écrase toi
c'est moi qui gère et c'est vrai que
cette image là pour moi est très
parlante et du coup sur le long terme je
pense qu'il va réaliser aussi qu'un
moment donné qu est ce que j'ai fait et
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de là il ya
beaucoup de gens et en amérique et même
en amérique ou qui sont très très dur
avec avec megan qui pensent que c'est
elle qui la poudrerie côté voilà non
mais mais il ya un truc qui me choque
c'est que est-ce que ce qu'est ce qui
est important dans la vie c'est que
paris soit heureux avec sa femme et ses
enfants
ou est ce que c'est une famille des rois
et des reines et de l'oseille il ya un
moment il a fait un choix ça veut dire
quoi qu'il faut dire à sa femme
non je te mets de côté parce que j'ai
une position sociale à la au trône et c
où il faut choisir sa femme et
enfants voilà c'est la question qu'il
faut se poser et à un moment il est
heureux avec sa femme et ses gosses
qu'on lui foute la paix qu'est ce qu'on
s'en fout fait pas trop nous la rachel
qui est très très proche des rois là
exactement alors excusez ma quand on se
marie je crois qu'on dit pour le
meilleur et pour le pire
oui moi j'ai hâte pour le pire oui il a
pris le pirée a pris le meilleur à elle
sort prochainement un bouquin un bouquin
pour enfants inspiré donc d'harry avec
son fils bientôt elle va sortir un
bouquin inspiré de harry qui change les
couches du petit mais en fait tout ce
qu'elle peut prendre des windsor de la
royauté et de son mari c'est à son
avantage et lui qu'est ce qu'il a gagné
eh bien il a gagné qu'il a perdu toute
sa famille s'est mis à rouler sa famille
est à saluer mais cette interview
excuse moi mais on va se souvenir quand
même de la complicité qu'il y avait
entre kate william aboly on se souvenait
ben oui partagent avec moi oui on a pris
un thé avec le nom mégoter en angleterre
et que tu vis avec eux la presse en
parle tous les jours tu pouvais voir au
mariage
on l'a vu des millions des milliards de
gens ont pu le voir la complicité au
mariage de kate
il était très très très proches ils
étaient là et aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe c'est que lui eh bien il a perdu
sa vraie famille et on sait pas combien
de temps ça va durer avec avec tellement
une bonne nouvelle si jamais ça
risquerait peut-être de l'intéressé
christopher non franchement la rachète
tu veux la porte là tu dis n'importe
quand mais y aller moi je trouve que là
où le courageux dans cette histoire
c'est harry parce que et pour pour par
l'amour pour megan il a tout perdu son
titre face à fortune voilà tous ces
avantages enclume je crois pas amer mais
en tout cas en tout cas je trouve
triptyque gelin dire je le trouve très
courageux parce que par amour il a pris
tous les risques pour mégane et c'est
peut-être un pari risqué sur l'abîmé en
tout cas ici les sang et or par six ans
son mari pourra s'en prendre qu'à
lui-même et moi je trouve ça magnifique
chemin bah oui oui qu'est ce qui a je
crois que la liberté n'a pas de prix
le harcèlement qu'a subi sa mère quand
même pendant des années la pas envie
qu'elle se reproduise avec la mère de
ses enfants rite lamoureux sa mère la
rue accord mais il a prouvé qu'elle nous
excusions mais quand vous épousez le
futur roi d'angleterre excusez moi quand
vous déposez une famille royale vous
devez quelques quand même quelques
quelques règles à ne pas passer non plus
jamais seul maire louis barye parce que
moi je savais les gens qui s'engagent
pour ce qui pleureront sur le prince
harry dans dix ans le temps et on est
dedans pas le temps des postures pour
moi ce qui est d'ailleurs en fait je
disais en fait le truc c'est que harry
il aspire à être lui même et pas à ce
qu'on lui impose d'être c'est à dire
qu'il ya un moment donné comme dit si
bien maxime dans le passé il a été quand
même traumatisé par certaines par
certains événements et qu'aujourd'hui
ils aspirent à une vie heureuse
peu importe s'il doit perdre l'argent ou
pas irrespect sa famille c'est eux qui
veulent pas respecter sa vie en fait
voilà bah écoutez moi je pense que ça
suppose que sa grand-mère de très triste
voilà où mène son petit préféré le
nippon pas l'accepter paris et je pense
que sa vie - nothomb à
facetime écoutons et sera l'invité louis
on doit éviter